hey guys how's it going so I wanted to
give you an air pods update I've had
them for over a week now I have a lot of
complaints especially on Twitter because
I was kind of just making fun of them
for the sake of making fun of them
because they're so easy to make fun of
but all things considered they don't
stay that well in my ears but they do
stay well enough if I'm not doing
anything super super crazy I made a
video talking about ear pods on the
plane which was basically only a
30-second clip inside of a 20 minute
vlog and people got very upset about it
I'm sorry I wanted you to see the vlog
so I had a title at something that I
know you would click this video I
promise you is only about the air pods
but also I will feature a couple other
headphones that I'm currently using what
I like most about these is how quick
they connect to my iPhone and to my Mac
so the main downfall for me with these
is obviously the huge one that they
don't stay that well in my ears I think
that's a knee problem it's not in
everyone problem because of my
complaining on Twitter a bunch of people
said I don't have that problem I'm able
to work out I'm able to do things that I
normally would with any pair of
headphones and they do not fall out so
it really is a case-by-case issue a huge
huge major flaw for me is because they
are bluetooth there is a slight lag in
audio what I'm using my MacBook and I'm
editing now this isn't just air pods
this is a Bluetooth issue there is that
small bit of lag so if I'm editing
something that I need to be editing to
music I can't use these there's
absolutely no way because the beat will
be off in the music that I'm singing to
is not what I'm actually hearing so I am
using these and I'm editing to music I
have to actually use the waveforms so
that I know where the beat is so that I
can edit and make the cuts there because
I can't rely on what I'm actually
hearing and editing too because it's not
going to match up I am very excited
though because these headphones I think
have been discontinued for a really long
time from Bose unless is one of the
first pairs of expensive headphones that
I'd ever purchased years and years and
years ago but since then they were
broken and I couldn't find them anywhere
they didn't have them online I didn't
want to get a used pair of eBay I went
to the Bose outlet and I saw that they
had these and I was like so what I like
about these is they go over your ears
for whatever reason what I have
headphones that are really big and over
top of my ear stand up giving me a
headache or even the kinds they have
like the little holes in them they go
over top of my ears I just don't like it
actually if I'm editing and doing
something for a lot of time I just can't
have that on my
so these are one of the only pairs of
headphones that ever really worked for
me and I didn't want to get Bluetooth
ones because I can't deal with the lag
so these ones are the wired version so
this is what I'm gonna be using to edit
what I need to have things plugged in
but if this is too big to carry these
are the both sport version which I don't
like as much but I did have to change
out these ear tips to another pair that
I found on Amazon they were just the
replacement ones I think Bose has
changed something in the last like year
or two because these are not the same
sounding as they used to be feel like
the sound quality when I first got a
pair of these maybe three four years ago
it was so much better and they stayed
better in my ears so they definitely
changed something and I'm not sure what
it was if any of you guys know let me
know in the comments it could be because
they made these ones water-resistant I
mean that's really the only thing that I
can think of and I do like that they
have a microphone built-in so I do a lot
of phone calls and conference calls so
these are the ear pods to come with the
iPhone 7 and I basically just kind of
carry these around as a backup because
there's been times where I need
headphones and I don't have them and I
don't have my dongle so these always do
come to the rescue
they also don't stay in my ears very
well but they do stay well enough that I
can listen to music or if I'm editing I
can't use these because it's a lightning
cable and I have nowhere to plug this in
but thinkin Apple good thinking so all
in all bear pods the top thing is that I
like is they're super small the design
of this little thing is just so compact
and so cool that I haven't even had to
charge these since I got them and that's
it if they just they just go in it's
automatically connecting to my phone
they're so easy I don't even have to
think about anything it's just it's
magic it really does feel like magic I
can just throw these into my bag it's
super small don't worry about cords
don't really worry about anything except
losing them the big downfall like I said
is that they don't say very well in my
ears and a little bit of lag when I
connect them to my computer and I'm
editing you also can connect these to an
Android or any other device that does
have bluetooth but you do have to
actually set it up and make any changes
using your iPhone as long as you have
bluetooth you're able to pair these and
use them on any other device so that's
pretty cool I'd be interested to hear
how these work out for you guys like I
said especially on Twitter I heard a lot
of people saying that they didn't work
for them but then a lot of people were
saying they were perfectly fine for me
so I don't know why you're complaining
and I wasn't
I'm planning I again I was just poking
fun because it's it's so easy to I do
really like them I mean this these are
my headphones right here in this little
tiny thing
I don't worry about cords I don't have
to worry about big cases I do have to
worry about charging it and I just wish
I wish so much this was us BC because
now basically everything is USB C and
except the iPhone 7s the 7s is going to
have to be a USB see like if it's not
I'm gonna throw a fit I'm going to throw
an absolute fit it'll be a great YouTube
video but it's a fit that I don't want
to have to throw all right guys I'm
gonna let you go I just want to give you
a quick update on what I thought about
the air pods and yeah that's all cool
see you guys later
in the Box spot on the box might need a
couple extra said maybe some extra
people will come home look well oh yeah
I get the napkins to forget those
napkins
you gotta get this big serving platter
yeah you gotta get this big bowl for the
pretzels